what about changes in mate preferences
what they look for in men yes
yeah it's interesting and so this is you
know
you know and I noted that
in about 20 to 30 years now that
researchers have been looking at the
effects of women's ovarian hormones on
their partner preferences and as noted
um when women are at the point in the
cycle when estrogen is high there's been
a lot of research indicating that they
they tend to exhibit a heightened
preference for cues to in particular
masculinity that's the one that seems to
be the most replicable with women
exhibiting a preference for more
masculinized male faces more
masculinized male voices the scent of
testosterone so men with the high
testosterone if you like have women's
sniffing t-shirts women prefer the scent
of men with higher levels of
testosterone
um and and so there's been a lot of
research that sort of links estradiol to
testosterone preference and so more
recently researchers have begun to
explore the idea that women who are on
hormonal birth control given that it
keeps your own estradiol levels very low
and the synthetics are also gives you
very low dose that this might be
associated with a decreased preference
for masculinity and there is some
evidence that is consistent with this
there's been research showing that women
who are on hormonal birth control prefer
a less masculinized male face relative
to what's preferred by the exact same
women when they are naturally cycling
there's been research where they've
looked at men who are in committed
relationships and they simply asked men
and their Partners did your partner
choose you when she was on or off of
hormonal birth control and then they
took the men's pictures and they sorted
the pictures into two piles right piles
of pictures of men who were chosen by
women who were using the pill and then a
pile of pictures of men who were chosen
by women who were naturally cycling and
they had them evaluated by an outside
group of evaluators who didn't know who
was what and you know was under what
circumstances and what they found was
that
both in terms of objective measures of
facial masculinity which is something
that you can look at using a facial
height to width because that's something
that's associated with testosterone
levels and then just having outside
evaluators evaluate subjective
masculinity the male faces and what you
see is that there are differences
between those two groups of men and that
the women or pardon me the men who were
chosen by women when they were on
hormonal birth control those faces were
seen as being less masculine and also
sort of scored lower in terms of
masculinity using the objective measures
relative to the faces of men who are
chosen by naturally cycling women and so
all of this again is consistent with
this idea that the pill could
potentially impact our partner
preferences and we have some new
research and I didn't write about this
in my book just because we're getting
ready to publish this but we've been
we've been working with natural cycles
which is a cycle tracking app where they
use basal body temperature to sort of
track fertility I mean a lot of way
women use it either as birth control to
like see when they're ovulating and then
not having sex or they use it when
they're trying to conceive seeing when
they're ovulating so they do have sex
and we send a survey to their users
asking them about what type of birth
control they were on when they chose
their partners and then we tracked the
women's sexual behavior over the course
of three Cycles
okay so this doesn't necessarily tell us
anything about like what it you know
tell us about your mate but what we were
able to do is look at whether or not
women who chose their Partners when they
were on the pill are having less sex
with those Partners now that they're
naturally cycling relative to what you
see among women who chose their Partners
while they're naturally cycling and now
they're naturally cycling right and
that's exactly what we found so we found
that over the course of the cycle that
women who chose their Partners when they
were on birth control or on hormonal
birth control they have less sex with
their Partners even now that they're off
of birth control then they're um then
then their counterparts who were on who
were not on hormonal birth control the
entire time and what's really
interesting about it is we also looked
at differences in logged libido between
those two groups of women
and there were no differences in libido
right so the women who were who chose
their partners and they were on the pill
or women who chose their partners and
they were off the pill they both had
comparable sex drive it's just that the
women who chose their Partners when they
were on the pill or having less you know
like Translating that sexual desire into
sexual behavior their Partners less
frequently uh than the women who chose
their Partners while naturally cycling
why do you think that is I think that
what the birth control pill essentially
does by flattening our you know
cyclically changing hormones and sort of
minimizing the role of estrogen in terms
of our partner choice and partner
preferences and the types of qualities
that we're attuned to when we're
choosing mates
um I think that it sort of downplays the
importance of sexiness in women's
partner choice and I think that it's
just sort of nudging that in terms of
like the you know women are making
choices about a partner
um you know you have to make a balance
like okay do I want you know somebody
who's a really good provider you might
want somebody like with really
interesting personality do I want you
know we have to sort of pick and choose
and I think that when you have your hpg
or your brain over ovarian axis shut
down and you're not experiencing all of
the things that estrogen does for
women's sexual desire I think that it
makes you downplay the importance of
sexiness in your partner choice and I
think that it's like you tend to go
after the more intangibles or pardon me
the tangibles right like okay is this
person going to be a good provider is
this person you know a stable and you
know emotionally stable and and so on
and so forth and there's some evidence
that's consistent with this like they've
been studies where they've looked at how
satisfied women are with different
aspects of their relationship based on
whether they chose their partner when
they were on or off the pedal and what
they find is women who chose their
Partners while they were on the pill
report more satisfaction with things
like their Partners Financial resource
access oh because they're going to have
assessed them with greater scrutiny
around those things but perhaps
sacrificed for stuff like attraction
masculine dominance maybe status as well
would perhaps be a little bit less
important yeah yeah and they're in there
and nobody's looked at that those last
couple of questions like the the status
questions they did look at
um you know sort of like sexual desire
and that sort of thing within the
relationships and of course you know the
women who are naturally cycling reported
being more satisfied with the sexual
aspects of their relationship and the
women who chose their Partners on the
pill were more satisfied with the
financial provisioning
um sort of cues in their relationship
and I think that what it does I think it
just sort of tilts the hand
um in terms of like what qualities are
you going after
um and you know for better and For Worse
right like there can be a that it's it's
not necessarily good it's not
necessarily bad it just is different
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for a selection of
the best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]